Right, okay, then let me warmly welcome you all to the meteo app evening.
Before we get started, I'd just like to set out a few rules quickly.
Best thing is everyone mutes their microphone except me.
If you have questions, you can use — most of you know the function — the raise-hand button at the bottom.
Or there's the chat area where you can type something in.
But what I'd prefer is the raise-hand option, then I see it and I can respond to the question.
After about 40 minutes — actually before that, because this is the free Zoom version, so at 40 minutes it's basically done.
Then we'll definitely take a short break, use the bathroom, and then...
I'll send you a new link via WhatsApp afterwards for the next session.
I think two should be plenty.
But I can't give you the exact schedule.
It might be that a few more questions come up and I run a bit longer.
Good, so I'd like to wait for that.
My topic this evening is basically going through the individual apps that I use, one by one.
We'll go through how they work — what options the apps now offer —
and what settings I've made in some cases, just to give a better overview.
And at the end we'll also go through the individual data, specifically for wind, clouds, general weather situation.
So there we'll do...
There we'll do some concrete analysis.
But first I'd like to show you the individual apps from a functional standpoint
and then go a bit more into detail as far as the forecast is concerned.
Good, then I'll get started.
Let me show you the screen so you know where to look.
If you can now see my browser, you can see it.
Quick reaction please on what's visible to you in the browser.
I need to quickly check the function...
It's a bit tricky like this.
All clear, wonderful.
Then let's go back.
Okay.
So, this is the first app.
Windy — most of you are familiar with it.
Before we now go into the...
...into the app itself, I'd like to show you the settings.
I'd recommend changing them if you haven't already.
Specifically, for wind use km/h which is more familiar to us, for temperature use °C,
for pressure use hectopascals.
Those are basic settings you find by clicking the menu in the top right.
Then settings.
And then you have it in front of you and you can make certain adjustments.
Wind animation: normal or high.
High is okay.
The higher I set it, the more cluttered it feels.
Sorry, I mean the density here.
The higher you set the density, the more cluttered it becomes.
Try it.
But if you set the animation to high and the density a bit higher,
then you can distinguish stronger wind from weaker wind a bit better, in my view.
When you zoom in like that, you see clearly more particle flow and clearly more wind.
It can sometimes make it a bit clearer, but I prefer not to have it too dense.
Then on the right side you have the various selection options preset.
Wind is also the most important or most relevant for us.
But there are many other cool functions, among them satellite images, which are important for clouds.
Radar — I haven't had such good experiences with that.
Rain, thunderstorms.
On the right side also precipitation included.
I have to honestly admit, Windy hasn't necessarily produced perfect forecasts for Switzerland in particular.
So with Windy I actually focus on wind, occasionally — especially abroad — also clouds.
And the second most important thing on Windy is definitely temperature.
That's a cool example right now, today, to read off the Foehn in tricky situations — when it's less than 4 hPa — using the temperature difference between the southern Alpine main ridge and the northern side.
And the topic that we have a decent difference there.
Now you should always set the altitude too, when we're on the right...
...then set the altitude to about 2000 metres.
Then it's very clear that we have a strong difference there.
And as a result the Foehn really is very actively in motion.
As I said, you also again have the altitude for each wind to choose from.
That works very well for us, of course.
We can come more clearly.
...go significantly higher and look, zoom out a bit more.
Windy really has all the options available and you can really see strong-wind bands very well.
If we now drop to a lower altitude, where it gets a bit more interesting,
say 1000 metres, then with one glance on Windy you can very easily see
how strong the wind is perhaps in our area and where the next, rather stronger wind band is.
Is it in our immediate vicinity or as we see here,
mind you at a low altitude of just about 1000 metres, in the Mittelland, right?
So for me Windy is actually a quite special display,
because it really shows things very visually.
And you can also see very well where there's strong wind, where less wind.
I find that quite neat and it also makes things very visible.
Then we have the possibility to select different weather models.
That's at the bottom.
We also have the option, for instance, to overlay paragliding launch sites.
Although that's also not really...
You can also again the wind...
...display direction and strength there as numbers.
But I find that makes everything a bit cluttered again.
That's why at the beginning I always take very little general information in.
What I have preset, what's always on, is the particle animation.
I think that's the case for most of you.
But what you could also turn on, which from my point of view also makes sense,
are the isobars — the lines of equal pressure.
And from those you can also read off a great deal.
And the cool thing is, down there with the time slider you can also step forward a bit
and see how the highs and lows are generally shifting.
So I find that quite neat.
You can really look at the whole thing well in advance, to see if it'll come like that.
You know that yourselves.
I wouldn't take that as gospel.
Anything beyond two days out is pure speculation for me, that's why.
But certainly good to see, and from my point of view very helpful — the isobars.
That's why I have them permanently turned on.
Depending on the model.
So there are...
You can also check when they get updated.
You have to click the info button for that.
Then you have the respective model with the grid it's computed on.
Nine-kilometre grid, European model.
And then you see how often the whole thing gets updated.
Six- to seven-hour interval.
It's actually not so...
But then you also know, okay, in about an hour and a half the update is coming.
That means it doesn't necessarily make sense to check every few minutes.
Because the whole thing is updated only a few times throughout the day.
And you can pull the info from there.
If we go to the German one now.
From the German Weather Service.
There you see it's updated every three to five hours.
So clearly shorter intervals.
But you can also see, if we zoom out now,
that the German model also doesn't cover such a large area.
That means if you're down in Spain,
and the European model with the 2.2-km grid is in front of you here,
then you have to go a bit...
...bigger.
ICON EU with 7 km or with 13 km.
So you see, you have the various models available.
Personally I work at the beginning to give myself a rough overview.
So the further out my forecast is,
the sooner I work with the European model as a base.
And the closer the whole thing gets,
also with...
...the sooner I move to a somewhat smaller grid.
Here in Switzerland,
or rather in the Alpine region,
I really like using ICON-D2.
It fits very well, in terms of frequency.
And I find that especially for our region,
the forecasts are clearly or very often accurate.
Not always, but quite often...
So that's about the inputs, you can pull all that out from there.
And the various models —
you also have to compare them over time for your region,
see what's better for you or more accurate.
Then there are really cool ones,
yes, also across the whole week,
a general option
to look at the weather in a bit more differentiated way.
So not just the wind,
but generally a bit of everything at a glance.
If we now go to our region,
you have the option
to take a specific moment,
normally this view opens up.
There you have it very simply: clouds, sun symbols.
You can have the ground brought in here.
You even have precipitation included.
But that's then more,
more for the coarser forecasts.
For us specifically,
you can call up so-called meteograms.
Or what's actually even a bit better for us,
because the wind is also brought in in more detail across the altitudes,
is the so-called Airgram.
So you can see the various altitudes there,
the wind at the various altitudes,
distributed over the day.
You have a display at the bottom,
of which clouds are likely to be encountered at which level.
And you also have the precipitation forecast included.
So they're actually very good and interesting.
There too you can switch between the individual models
and then you get the forecast from them.
The other one is
the American model,
that's the model
that's been recording the longest,
so where the most data is available,
but it also has the largest grid at 22 km.
And I really only use that one now
if I'm looking at a forecast more than a week out.
Because everything else, from my point of view, has by now
become rather imprecise.
And now comes a really cool function in the options.
So you see down here,
I have a 1-hour forecast.
That's only possible
if you've taken out the subscription with Windy.
It costs around 18 euros something.
So it's really not expensive.
You have to decide for yourself whether it's worth it or not.
But now comes a really great function.
Namely, you can here
with compare,
you can now compare all the models with each other
for the individual day.
That means if here, like now for tomorrow,
practically all models predict no precipitation,
then you can assume that's how it's going to come.
If they all disagree,
one says precipitation, another doesn't, another again does,
then it's a bit trickier,
but when it's as clear-cut as here,
then you can assume
there will definitely be no precipitation.
And that's actually a really cool function.
It helped me a lot in India, for example,
to also quickly see
which models work even better in that location than others.
But that, in turn, I find a really, really cool function.
Yes, Windy, another quite special tool
if you also want to analyse the thermals.
However, this here is a bit trickier,
because you have to understand the emagram significantly more.
I'll give an example, if we zoom in there
and I move to the valley floor in our region,
let's do that in Klima.
Then you have to right-click with the mouse
and another grid opens up
with various options.
And then you have to go to Aerology at the very bottom
and then the so-called emagram opens up on the right,
or Temp, as the Germans call it.
And I've set this down here to SkewT.
So you can choose the normal view,
I don't quite recall the name,
or you can have the whole thing on SkewT and that's what I use,
that's what I learned to work with.
And then you can actually also analyse the temperature curve
down there.
What's really cool, you see it displayed now,
if you move the cursor back and forth there,
you can actually also read off the cloud base
with cloud top very easily.
But of course you have to in general
generally know how to handle it.
That means it doesn't help you
if you haven't really done much
with the emagram before.
But it's very possible
to read off the cloud base there.
For those who can or need it,
they can at least, based on the temperature
of the state curve, classify with humid or non-humid.
So the EFS model is set there now.
You can really switch between the individual models there.
And you see that the German model
already calculates quite differently from the American one.
And what's actually very visible for you
is this red curve.
You can see how steeply the curve goes upward,
is the temperature decreasing well
or do we have, like down there, an increase,
i.e. an inversion in there.
Then you can at a glance see
how far apart the temperatures are
and temperature and dew point are.
That means, less cloud formation
or, like up there, permanent cloud formation.
Plus you have on the left, on the bar along the altitude line,
as it were also an indication of cloud cover.
So actually a lot of information is available.
You just have to be able to read it off.
With the SkewT, the temperature lines are like that.
They're arranged regionally.
You may also need a certain time
to get familiar with it.
But for me personally that's definitely one of the best tools
to thermally prepare for the relevant day.
Good, so you really see very, very many functions.
For wind you can step through the individual altitudes.
It's just that the smaller the grid gets,
the less far you can look into the future.
And in some cases you're also limited in altitude.
It works here.
But with the 1.3-km grid,
you can, to my knowledge, only look at the surface wind.
Which might be quite good for wind formation,
because it's only the pure surface.
But otherwise we don't really need many forecasts for the surface wind.
But depending on the grid you can't look as far into the future.
That's why I always recommend at the beginning,
to be able to look far into the future,
see how far we can actually look these days.
And in order to at least be able to do some planning,
the European grid and then, depending on the location,
so in Spain I have, down there,
I picked the ICON EU7.
Let's take a quick look at it.
It also worked in Spain.
Although in Spain Windy actually, in terms of forecast,
fairly often didn't work well.
So you really have to check, depending on the location,
how reliable the forecast is.
In India, super.
In Spain not quite so good.
There the second app, which we'll get to in a moment,
was significantly better, I have to say.
So the hit rate was significantly higher.
But as I said, the zooming in and out
makes areas significantly more visible.
And I always recommend starting from the top down,
i.e. zoom out further
and then keep going further into the image.
That's an advantage for any forecast anyway.
No hands.
All good. Wonderful.
Okay.
Actually that's already pretty much it.
As I said, you still have so many options.
Just work your way through.
You can lose yourself in it a bit.
Right now, specifically for clouds
I'd also include this view.
Recommended.
But especially abroad
it very rarely matched.
Take the forecast really with caution.
So you can also go down to this view.
Clouds, sometimes a forecast away from the satellite image.
If you want to look further into the future
and it unfortunately hasn't worked so well abroad so far.
On a day like Friday now,
where it's already clear that low clouds
are coming in with that front,
then the forecast there is also right.
But on days where it's still a bit trickier,
I haven't done so well so far.
The same applies likewise to
precipitation in general.
We'll go into that a bit more later with the other apps.
Good. Then I'd actually leave Windy at that.
And move on to the next app.
That would be Meteo-Parapente.
That's one of my absolute favourite apps,
because in terms of presentation, from my point of view,
there's almost nothing better.
Nothing simpler, nothing clearer at a glance.
So I find it really outstanding.
We have only 10 minutes left and we've just been notified.
So we have about 8 minutes left.
And then I'll start a new session afterwards.
Definitely.
This one is also paid.
If not, if you use the basic or free version,
then there's an algorithm in the background
that locks some day, or sometimes even multiple days.
Which means you also don't know which day.
It could be tomorrow.
It could be today.
So if you want to use it permanently,
you almost have to subscribe.
But there too, it costs 24 euros for a whole year,
that's actually very cheap and offers really, for the
average pilot, almost everything you need.
Wind forecast, thermal forecast, cloud amount, precipitation amount, thermal top,
even with colours sub-dividing the strength.
So really, everything is there.
In that respect I find it really very good.
What's not quite so easy here is getting the overall overview.
Of course you can also zoom out further.
But the direct view of where you have
areas with stronger wind, I find Windy does that much better.
But if you go into detail there,
and what I'd really recommend if you do that,
is that you don't just look at your own location,
but perhaps also call up places in the nearby area.
What just happened?
Do you still have my screen?
Maybe I can quickly poke someone and ask if you...
Yes, okay, all clear. You still have my screen.
As I said, you should make sure you stay in the area.
Not just at the place where you fly,
but also look at the wind in the surroundings.
And on my end this opens automatically,
but for you it looks like this at the beginning.
And if you click on the diagram on the right,
then you get a good display.
You have the altitude, you have the whole degree spread.
So from 5, 6, 7, 8 onwards.
And in the evening, what's recorded is the wind at the various altitudes
with parts of the route.
So the stronger the wind, the thicker.
And the darker, the stronger the wind.
They're even oriented specifically for the paraglider.
So green and yellow are still flyable.
And at orange-red it's no longer flyable.
And I just find this extremely good in terms of presentation.
You can immediately see at a glance
at which altitude there's enormous amounts of wind.
Or like here, for example.
Yes, here the wind picks up extremely well.
What you have to watch out for with Meteo-Parapente,
or have to watch out for, simply keep in mind,
you can subtract a good 5 to sometimes 10, sometimes even 15 km/h,
subtract.
So it tends to calculate too strong.
But that's preferable to the other way round, for me.
What works very well, though, is the direction.
And only yesterday I got a message again from PiPi,
who is still travelling in Spain.
And there Meteo-Parapente again delivered an absolutely spot-on forecast.
So in terms of timing, even of strength,
and wind direction, it matched perfectly.
And so of course you can also work and decide really, really well,
where to go.
And Meteo-Parapente, I have to say, doesn't yet hit it for us
as often quite as well,
but abroad it's outstanding.
So if you go abroad, Meteo-Parapente is almost mandatory,
because it works extremely well.
And the great thing is, you also have at a glance the cloud amount
or at which level the cloud is located.
You see that here, these clouds.
If there's precipitation,
let me go back to Friday,
in case there's precipitation now,
you also see the clouds at the levels, partially right down to the ground.
And then you see down there,
with 0.2, 0.1, the precipitation is added.
Actually everything you need.
And really at a glance for the whole day.
And there too it's now the case — that wasn't quite given at the beginning,
but now it's the case that you can look at data in advance.
And I just find from the presentation,
where you can quickly get an overview at a glance
of how it's likely to look across the whole day.
If we now go back to the wind,
which is also super for the wind,
but if we now look at all of Thursday,
then we have to go through every single altitude for each time.
That means we have to look at what's happening at 2,000 metres,
or at 3,000 metres, 4,000 — so we have to go through every altitude.
And we have to remember it.
Ah yes, on the 6th in the evening for example,
at 2,000 metres there's decent wind to deal with.
You really have to remember that and it takes a lot of time.
If we now jump back to Meteo-Parapente,
I still have two minutes — if we go back there to Meteo-Parapente,
then we have at a glance, we see immediately,
for example, when the wind picks up extremely from below.
So we have maybe in the lower view an area
that's quite good or usable, but already an hour later
we have a decent wind increase from 5 pm onwards.
The storm breaks through extremely there down to the bottom.
I find that makes it extremely quickly visible.
When do we have a problem?
When is it perhaps no problem?
When is it still well flyable?
And when do you really have to watch out?
I find that very, very good.
Then we have up at the top right, next to the diagram,
we have the thermals, so to speak.
So here too you can of course still
change the setting between km/h knots and meters per second.
I always like km/h.
And from my point of view, here too the M-A gram
has been modified user-friendly.
That means they have their own interpretation of this M-A gram.
And specifically they've done it so that this right state curve
is made recognisable with their own colours.
That means black is actually a rather stable stratification.
So temperature gradient is, decreases very minimally
or is sometimes maybe even constant.
So isothermal or an inversion that would have a really stabilising effect.
And the green range is already a range
where it's still slightly unstable, but already more usable for us.
So that's why also green.
Thermally speaking, more usable for us.
And red would now be very strong for us.
So almost no longer flyable.
Not even a minute more.
We'll stop at that point in a moment.
I'll come back later to this M-A gram.
Or rather to the Temp from Meta-Power.
But I want to end it here now.
And I'll send you straight away, when the season, when things...